hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the candidates tournament it's
no longer a mystery uh regarding who
will challenge magnus carlsen in
november it is of course yanipanishi but
uh there's still one more round to go
and it's
it's pretty much unlike any other
tournament because in every other
tournament uh you know
uh getting second place or getting third
place kinda
is a consolation prize but there's also
better money of course but here in the
candidates tournament it's kind of all
about
that first place uh but still yeah this
is a very nice game so
i decided to show it from the final
round uh dean leeron uh against the
annie point she didn't had a terrible
first half of the tournament last year
but now
uh he improved drastically as he already
won two of his previous games
uh and uh you know if he can take one
more win with the white pieces could go
a long way at least you know not to lose
uh not to lose rating
uh so without further ado let's check it
out and let's see if maybe jan can get
uh his rating up to 2800 maybe if he
beats ding then he crosses 2800 and then
he can challenge magnus
uh we're gonna have a nice clash of two
twenty eight hundred players so here
being with the white pieces opens with
d4
uh we have knight to f6 c4 g6 bion
we have f3 uh as sort of the uh
anti-groom grunfeld defense uh and e6
now
uh not defense and anti-grunfeld
variation
uh so e6 now and now e4 grabbing a lot
of space in the center here
we have c5 striking in in the center
with
uh with the c pawn and now d5 being
advances the pawn we have d6 now
and the bishop to d3 and already this is
a very very rare position
only uh i think one other game reached
this position where e capture sandify
was played
but here in yeppo goes bishop to g7 and
it is already as of move six that we
have a completely new game
so let's see how ding uh deals with this
we have
knight to e2 and now e captures on d5
grabbing that pawn in the center we have
c
captures on d5 and now knight beat the
d7 that we have
knight eat the c3 now uh and now comes
a6 preparing to further expand on the
queen side with b5
so of course ding stops this with a4 and
now comes
knight to h5 uh now opening up the dark
squares now the knight nicely covers g4
uh uh f4 g3 the bishop can come to d4
deliver
check maybe in the future the queen can
come to a for a h4 threaten some
uh checkmating idea so it's you know all
the usual stuff when you play uh this
kind of line with the black pieces so
here
ding boldly castles and bishop to d4
with check so here you have to move the
king king to h1
and now it seems like a reasonable idea
to bring the queen to h4 because now
you're threatening checkmate
uh the bishop prevents the king from
reaching g1 so knight to g3 would be
checkmate
however here just queen e1 and you don't
really have an attack here
best for black is probably trade queen
queens here
uh or to go back with some like queen to
d7 queen to
e8 and then white is the one who starts
uh seizing the initiative
so instead after king to h1 knight to e5
neville brings the knight into the
attack puts pressure and the bishop on
d3
but now of course uh knight to e2 going
after the bishop on d4
we have queen to h4 and now comes knight
captures on d4 so eliminating this
monster of a bishop if you don't do this
there's again this threat of knight to
g3
not for the moment for the movement the
knight guards the g3 square but it's
best just to get rid of that bishop so
knight captures on d4
knight captures on d3 queen captures and
now
of course as the queen is spinning the
h2 pawn
knight the that's not a knight knight
the g3 with
check forking the king and the rook so
you have to play king to g1
and now comes knight captures on f1
and this is just uh this is just a you
know wonderful wonderful move
uh because it uh uh not only
uh grabs a rook but also prevents white
from
uh capturing this knight or capturing
the h2 pawn
uh problem is uh if you go after it then
this knight escapes so here we have
knight to c2
getting this knight at the safety and
now comes
knight captures an h2 you could also go
queen captures an h2 check but then
comes king captures an f1 and you don't
really have
anything here you could maybe deliver
one more check queen to h1
king f2 and that's it if queen to h4
you're just gonna play king the g1 and
now there are no more checks the
knight covers the e1 square and that's
pretty much it uh
from black so instead after knight to c2
we have knight captures on
h2 this is how the the knight escapes
and
here nepo is just up material he has two
rooks ding only has one rook
uh but uh how are you getting this
knight uh
back into the game because these two
squares are covered and there is
no easy way to do it and it would be
very very easy for dink to mess this up
if he gives nipple just one move if he
gives him g5 for example if you play
something like knight to c3
if nipple can get g5 in then all of a
sudden black is just uh you know
okay g4 is coming and you will be able
to get this knight back into the game
so instead after this knight captures an
h2 ding plays the absolute strongest
queen to e3 he prevents the g
pawn from reaching g5 and now nepo has
to decide what to do but
uh you know queen to g5 is coming and
you will have to give up this knight on
h2
so here we have castles uh now with idea
so maybe f5 maybe we can open up the f
file for the rook but now
queen g5 as planned knight captures on
f3 with
check probably best there is not much
for this night left to do the queens are
getting traded so the knight will fall
g captures and now queen to h3 uh
keeping the queens
on the board and maybe maybe you can
still open up the position somehow
the problem is that black uh black does
have two rooks on the bishop but they're
doing absolutely nothing here
and here while the f3 pawn is under
attack if ding defends it with something
like king to f2 then f5 and all of a
sudden
uh black's position comes alive so ding
says nope
uh your your pieces are completely
undeveloped we're just gonna play bishop
to f4 we're gonna develop a piece
offer you the f3 pawn and now if you
grab it you're just going to be so
so behind in development that i don't
think you will be able to recover
and other than capturing an f3 there
really isn't a
a better plan here uh for example f5
here can just be met with bishop
captures on d6 and now this rook
will not really be all that impressive
if you go for example rook to f7 to keep
an eye on ndf file
queen to d8 check and that's uh you know
just a
terrible terrible position for black
king g7 knight can come to d2
and you will you will never break
through here captures captures and
uh okay you could go for something like
this or queen captures but there is no
there is no attack here for example
bishop to e5 check and
you're just getting checked made it came
to h6 queen to g5 check there are
uh many many options here uh so instead
after bishop to f4
uh ding decided to capture on f3 and now
comes
knight the d2 attacking the queen and
now the rook can happily
join the rest of the pieces and here uh
we have
f6 which brings us to our first pause
the video moment so feel free to pause
the video here
and how do you how do you counter this
f6 idea by nipple
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
playing the only move that makes sense
and for those who
just want to enjoy the show okay you
could just move the queen back that also
makes sense but
uh grabbing a pawn while you're at it
makes even more sense
queen captures and g6 is the way to go
uh this is what being played and he went
for a queen trade here
captures captures and captures and now
bishop to g4 and nipple brings the
bishop into the game
and now just knight back to d2 and now
the problem is how are these rooks
getting into the game
we have bishop to e2 first uh
remaneuvering the bishop to d3 we have
king to f2 bishop to d3
and now knight to e1 chasing the bishop
further back we have c
for now defending the bishop and now
comes bishop captures on d6
grabbing that pawn and now white has a
really really
strong past d-pawn we have rook after e8
uh
and now comes knight captures on d3
c captures and bishop to c7 there is
nothing you can do against the d6
and then when this bishop pawn battery
is created here on c7 and d6 squares
the rooks will be completely helpless
against it so king to f7 we have rook to
a3
time to activate the rook we have rook a
to c8 and now of course
d6 we have king to e6 and
now comes rook captures on d3 we have
king to d7
now comes knight the c4 with the idea of
knight to b6 check just winning material
here
so here nipple played rook captures on
c7 but now
just for fun feel free to pause the
video again and find the quickest way to
victory
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting uh
well either the captures on c7 this is
winning but
the uh shortest uh weight to victory is
knight to b6 or rather the quickest way
to victory is knight to b6 check
uh andy was in this position on move 35
that yanni pony should resign to the
game
uh but regardless he's still the winner
of the candidates tournament because
even if geary wins the final game
uh doesn't matter they will be tied in
points but uh
jan defeated geary in the first half of
the tournament so he has a positive
result against him
and of course that is uh is a tiebreaker
in this case so here he resigns
uh because it doesn't matter where you
go if you go king to c6
attack the knight then uh just pawn
captures and that's it
if you capture the the knight then just
rook here and then you remove the rook
and then we get a queen into the game or
you capture and then we again get a
queen into the game
or after knight the b6 check you could
just move the king to d8 but
that's uh you know the the the position
that we already discussed just 95 and
white is up uh up a night and this is
this is unplayable for black
uh you're also losing the f6 pawn so
there's that uh
so yeah after rook captures on c7 sorry
after night the b6 checkian
resigned the game and this is ding's
third win in a row in the second half of
the tournament
so ding really woke up in the second
part of the candidates tournament but
it was much too late because he simply
suffered uh
two too many losses in the first half
and it was not enough so we're going to
discuss the final standings i will do at
least one more game from from the final
round
so stay tuned for that and uh once again
thank you all for watching
uh i would like to thank tiberio craig
wall uh charlie hughes happy birthday
chrissy
and john mcnabb for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day